from poker to joker lady gaga joins the
dc universe and seemingly as the iconic
villain's equally iconic love interest
harley quinn
[Music]
here's what we know so far gaga will be
starting alongside joaquin phoenix in
the long-awaited joker sequel
it's not a joke
[Laughter]
yeah it's no joke the singer broke the
exciting news in this first look
featuring her and joaquin's silhouettes
[Music]
yep all signs point to her playing the
infamous harley quinn his psychiatrist
at arkham asylum who becomes his partner
in crime
this is exactly how i imagined it
and we imagine there might be a love
match between the two characters in the
sequel because in the comics harley is
the joker's girlfriend talk about a bad
romance
[Music]
and get this the film will be right up
gaga's alley because it's a musical do
you know what you want to do next we
heard you might be writing a musical i
do have something in mind
for what's next uh but i'm i'm not going
to reveal it just yet if the speculation
is true the pop star will be following
in the footsteps of margot robbie and
kelly cuoco who have also taken on the
role of the clown prince's sidekick
margot in suicide squad and birds of
prey
[Music]
bye-bye birdie
no fear
is that really necessary
you don't know her like i do
while keeley voices the super villain in
hbo max's animated series harley quinn
there's only one thing stopping us from
being front page news no one's trying to
stop us gaga's journey as harley is set
to start in december when filming begins
gaga's latest gig comes on the heels of
her buzzworthy performance in 2021's
house of gucci and her oscar-nominated
role in 2018's remake of a star is born
i feel very seen in a way that my
my immersive approach to acting is
something that
is being celebrated which i appreciate
and the multi-talented artist has no
plans of stopping if you have inside you
something great that you wish to share
there will be somebody to receive it if
you have
the bravery within you and the courage
to keep going
[Music]